welcome back on this show we are
committed to bringing you the important
stories impacting the nation and also
providing solution
this week as part of our journey
together cross country i traveled to
massachusetts where i met a young woman
who is coming forward to share her story
on addiction and survival involves the
deadliest drug in america today and it's
impacting americans in each and every
state
it's called fendal
brittany's story began sadly like so
many other americans a progression of
addiction tonight she tells that story
in the hopes that it will save lives all
right brittany thanks for doing this
tell me
when was the first time you got high i
was 13 it started off with just
weed actually so that's how it started
off um i didn't like it though i
automatically got like a huge panic
attack everybody was telling me to like
run in circles told me it would get
better so i did and i
like freaked out
and then when i was 14 i tried vicodin
and this was in 2007
[Music]
but i really liked how it made me feel
but i had no idea what was going to
happen after that
so you went from weed to the pills and
then you have your first encounter with
fentanyl
yeah so i went to treatment when i was
18 years old for
benzos like xanax and
opiates in general
but when i got out i learned about all
the other
drugs like iv
like ways to use it
so 18 and a half to 19 that's when i
started
i don't think i knew was fentanyl in the
beginning but as i was more into it i
knew
that i was
definitely injecting fentanyl
and that was good that's what i wanted
today in america fentanyl overdoses have
skyrocketed shockingly the deadly
substance killed more american in the
country than car accidents last week
texas governor greg abbott issued this
warning to the nation
and called out the president the leading
cause of death of our fellow americans
ages 18 to 45
is fentanyl
and president biden is doing nothing
to address that fentanyl problem so
you've been in some dangerous situations
can you tell me a couple
yeah so
when i was living in south florida
i went to a motel to get drugs because
that was the normal thing to do for me
and i went up the stairs and i got
tricked by a group of drug dealers
they told me they had them but they
didn't have it and they locked the door
so i had to
make up a lie to get out of the room
when i got out of the room i didn't
realize that there were actually
10 or 15 of them they all came out from
different
sides of the
hotel how did you get away i just ran
i ran but they kept looking for me that
was the problem
and i went to a wendy's i had to ask the
manager to let me in so i could hide in
the bathroom
so you finally reached this breaking
point what is the breaking point
well the breaking point i was
10 weeks pregnant with my first child
and i overdosed what was that day like
for you
i just knew that
honestly i knew i was going to start
feeling her kick soon and that scared me
because then it was going to be real
that
that was it for you
why
and i just didn't want to do that to my
own child
that mattered to you yeah
it's okay it's okay it's okay
walk me through that
you feel that kick
and your next move is
i actually went to a
clinic which
i swore i would never do but i tried
everything
i actually had to go on medication to
come off of it what sort of medication
methadone
there's all these different programs
that believe that
part of the way that you help
individuals conquer this
is giving them needles clean needles
giving them the tools to do that or
giving them smaller doses what do you
think about those different programs is
that really healthy no i don't why
if i because i just think it's it's just
making it easier
because if i didn't overdose and i was
pregnant with my daughter i could just
go to a facility and shoot up i wouldn't
have stopped
i remember i said i was afraid i was
going to die if i had a place like that
why would i stop
fentanyl is impacting every corner of
the country on january 15th in the
neighboring hartford connecticut a
13-year-old boy overdosed and died in a
school bathroom
even more shocking police have now
reportedly found a hundred bags of the
powerful substance in his bedroom final
question
for the people that are watching or
someone that may be using right now
that's watching
if you had one thing to tell them just
one thing
what would that one thing be
just keep fighting
don't give up because
might not have worked last time but it
doesn't mean you can't
you can't get it
you just have to keep trying but
tomorrow might never come so
you gotta
do it now not
plan it out
it's never going to be enough thank you
so much i appreciate it hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else